oui alors vous êtes fatigué pourquoi
marca les chances de remporter le flou
parce que dans sa tête il n'y a aucune
chance qu'il ne remporte pas le flambeau
va gagner les 450 euros
450 euros une somme folle en mixant n'a
évidemment rien ne l'empêchera de gagner
les 450 euros ou n'approche pas
j'ai des nouveaux réflexes si on décide
que ce monde peut être remportée par des
gens qui sont sympas celle qu'il y ait
peut t'aider non surtout pas ça que la
piste comme un bon surréaliste d affûter
il est prêt sur alarme qui me font ni
fait pas les cours vis il est très
sympathique en fait mort donc c'est pour
ça qu'il a une chance de gagner
et au nickel plus de chances de
remporter le flambeau c'est un jeu
sportif est là pour une fois il ya que
du sport est un peu sa dernière chance à
50 balais de se dire avec cette aventure
je vais gagner ma première place au club
la dalle on vote contre lui ce soir toi
y'a quand même très très peu de choses
pour le rattraper et pourtant évidemment
ne les trahira pas des dégénérés des
mecquois physiquement elle est très en
forme et fait beaucoup de sport elle est
maligne elle est intelligente mais non
ouais j'en veux je suis cash quoi
occuper un ado j'ai pas tout lu du
scénario je suis incapable de vous dire
ce sujet et éliminer ou pop
je pas cotiser mais il faut qu'il y
arrive quel sera le prochain aventuriers
éliminés vous serez en regardant le
prochain épisode du flambeau les
aventuriers nunchuk
[Musique]
bienvenue sur cette île de chewbacca
bras vous allez devoir survivre pendant
38 jours sans rien vous êtes sûr que
c'est là parce qu'il n'y a pas de vie
d'un chien mâle kerry ont battu
construire nous mêmes tout construire
avec trois ânes nos mains peut-être
ils devront dépasser la fin on crève la
dalle il n'y a pas de déjouer l'ennemi
de dîners quoi
la fatigue va bien dormi lui tombe bien
oui les trahisons évidemment que je les
travaille on va te contredire ce soir
mais non en gros tu es mer dont la ford
ka
oh [ __ ] c'est aux sauvegardes un seul
de ses 14 aventuriers succèdera à lionel
quillet remporté 450 euros une somme
folle rien ne m'empêchera de gagner les
450 euros la guerre elle fait que
commencer j'ai envie de faire partie de
cette aventure humaine tais toi
maintenant belge n'a aucun secret pour
moi c'est la bonne humeur qui sera
larmes qui me fera gagner
tout est lente
[Musique]
frolon fait vomir c'est le seul moyen de
faire du poids rapidement au
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle le multiverse